en cluster IBC calling in from beautiful
Cambridge Massachusetts
how are y'all doing tonight oh call
streaming to you live from st. Louis is
Jerry GZ Zane
alright roll call
what's going on everybody Josh for Dale
called entry order nice roll call didn't
me yeah yeah okay so this is 10 now home
I'm enjoying a happy equality of live
only more because I'm a suspect it off
it be effective roll call
hey guys this is rich Kirby I'm calling
from our lovely campus I'm in Massey
Hall right now love you guys hmm I want
to give a special shout out to Peter got
our Wednesday here Peter hey how's it
going this is Peter Goddard I'm just a
few blocks from campus and East
Cambridge alright excited to be meters
gonna be joining us on a to and a little
later on in the show but he's on the
call for the whole time so we're glad to
have him with us I want to give a
special shout on something else on the
call Tom say hi Tom Tom's not expecting
to say anything
sometime we're waiting for you alright
alright well Tom so go tom is our
wonderful music tag event staff who is
helping us to stream this on YouTube so
we're really grateful to have with us
I mean I'm calling in from Somerville
Massachusetts and we're going to go
ahead and get started and make some
sound for you tonight feel free to to
get out of your chair this is not a
sitting use here kind of a show although
this is a show that we're clearly well
on headphones so actually I do recommend
you use headphones if you can but
otherwise just enjoy however you want to
do it alright here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we were going to try doing something
a little bit different now so that last
beast just tree by chance and haunts of
a remix of a piece that we did an
earlier concert and now we're gonna move
on to something slightly different we're
gonna do a little bit of a web audio
medley
so there's lots of really cool online
collaborative music making experiences
that people have made and we thought it
would be fun to go through and play some
of these for you as kind of an
experiment and also just to sort of
celebrate this kind of music making and
a lot of them actually are very fun and
it kind of dance born into well and in
there we're also gonna throw in one web
audio thing which is new created by a
family member
Ian cluster a little bit of a live
coding jams
we are going to this piece so this piece
is called interference it's by Matt
Lange who completed this piece was part
of his undergraduate work at Princeton
and he wrote it originally for the
Princeton laptop Orchestra so the
Princeton laptop Orchestra is run by
Jeff Snyder at Princeton University Matt
was a member for that and so he wrote
that for them and they've performed it a
number of times and we wanted to also
perform it as part of our concert so so
that was that man it looks like we got a
little bit of a discontinuity coming on
here because things did not get set up
the way that we need to them to get set
up so that's okay so we're going to go
ahead and get this rolling for you in
just a second
following this piece we're gonna do a
sequencer by a German fellow who I do
not know to show something I found
online and then after that we're gonna
have another piece another sequencer and
this one is gonna be really different so
Peter guard is gonna play keys on this
and he's going to be a guest artist for
that and that's using a sequence that's
built around free sound so free sound is
an online repository for sharing sound
files it's really a fun and very useful
website actually basically the lots of
people will contribute sounds they're
all our open-source licenses that people
can use them or use them for their own
work and so as part of that somebody
made a live collaborative music
sequencer where you can actually search
for audio files in real time from the
free sound library and throw those into
your sequencer and use them to to make
the sound so and that piece everything
that you're going to hear are gonna be
samples that are pulled from the free
sound audio library as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you worry
you're worried
you're wearing
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm just gonna end it right there
thank you everyone for coming and
joining this this was a fun experiment
for us I want to thank everybody am
sambala who contributed Ian's cluster in
Trenton Hong especially for contributing
pieces and everyone else who's been very
helpful in the organization and sort of
running of the of the concert and all
the preparation for it it's been a
really fun semester and we've got a lot
of really cool things I'm really
grateful to have this opportunity as
always to work with these talented young
musicians and get a chance to make this
kind of music and this is really new and
exciting entry so thank you for coming
and thanks for me part of it thank you
Peter got art for coming in being brave
enough to be part of this with very
short notice and little rehearsal thank
you Tom Amos and all of the music and
theatre arts event staff at MIT who are
always super helpful tom is an honorary
member of family now and probably
forever we will always be really
depending on his contributions and we're
really grateful for it so let's do a
quick sign-off this is Ian how working
Somerville Anita this is Anita from
Taiwan
Oh you Questor cambridge qz st. louis
josh Verdejo florida Richard Massey Hall
MIT cinta of one coffee from nineteen
quarantine facility and in Howard
Somerville and family online now and for
as long as we need to be thanks so much
we'll see you on the interwebs and
hopefully in and I've got the oh yeah so
just for for those who want to join us
and actually this is only for people who
are at MIT unfortunately you can come
and join you can come and join our
resume chat just to come and hang out
with us so I'm going to go ahead and
throw the zoom link in the YouTube chat
and send it out so feel free to come and
join us and say hi oops I can't do that
because my zooms has on another computer
or my youtube chance on another computer